and welcome back everybody in 2020 a man
named Tim bleefnik appeared on an
episode of Family Feud and when asked
what the biggest mistake was on his
wedding night his response was saying I
do that answer is now back in the
headlines as he stands trial in Illinois
for his wife's murder police and
prosecutors say Timothy belief Nick was
going through a contentious divorce with
his wife Becky when they claim he
decided to break into her home and kill
her in February of this year belief Nick
is charged with first-degree murder and
home invasion the prosecution says Becky
told friends that she was scared of what
the defendant might do to her to get
custody of her kids believe Nick had the
couple's Three Sons at his home the
night of the murder and allegedly left
them alone to go commit the crime his
defense team argues that this case is
quote dripping with Reasonable Doubt and
that a divorce alone is not enough to
convict their client Friday concluded
the first week of the prosecution's case
and they took the morning to call a
Quincy police detective to the stand he
said the last activity from the victim's
cell phone was an attempted 911 phone
call around 1am on the day she was
killed also read aloud was the
defendant's internet search history
found on his cell phone
homelyville.com how to open window from
outside yes
Google search can I force open my door
with a crowbar if I locked myself out
yes home emergency
Dot wonderhowto.com
how to open almost any door with easy
lock picking track yes phone was used to
search how many cups in Quincy Illinois
yes
that's fun phone was used to search how
to make a homemade pistol silencer that
is correct phone was used to search
average Quincy Police Department
response time that's correct
how can I check if a gun is registered
to me that's correct can you just wash
off gunpowder residue that's correct
can you identify if a shotgun shell was
shot out of a specific gun yes sir the
search is on the the cell phone uh do
not tell you that Tim did those searches
correct correct and they do not tell you
who had possession of that device the
time those searches were made correct
correct and in this case you do not have
any information of the location of the
phone the time those searches were made
correct correct and you don't know who
initiated those searches correct that's
correct simply that those searches were
done on that device correct yes with the
exception of one visit to one website
there are no times and dates associated
with the any of these searches correct
yes ma'am
I don't know anybody getting Brian Walsh
Vibes I mean Mike those are some pretty
damning searches you think the defenses
cross made them seem any less damning
attorneys we really can only work with
what we have
um I do though like this is not a
conversation like we said before that
somebody's having hit a bar it's in a
courtroom where the burn proof is beyond
the Reasonable Doubt and I think one of
the things that is a good argument for
the defense here is listen these are
searches you could find answers for on
the website they're not necessarily
illegal the questions he's asking nor do
they tie to the fact of who committed
the murder although once again
circumstantial evidence is always a
tough argument for a disability but it
does create strong circumstantial
evidence but is there proof to make it
proof beyond the Reasonable Doubt and
aside from those texts Terry before she
died Becky sent a text to her sister
saying that if any harm comes to her the
authorities should look at her husband
would that support an argument maybe
this was a crime of passion I don't
think this is really a crime of passion
here I think this was premeditated it
really does sound like based on the text
and based on the witness testimony that
we heard from a former colleague of her
husband that she expressed concerns
about him and that the authorities
should look at him if anything should
happen to her so the fact that she was
in fear of her life means that
something's going on prior to that event
usually when you have a crime of passion
it's something that was provoked or it's
in the moment I don't think we have that
here and of course you have all of those
searches that he was doing and again it
shows that he was thinking about the
crime of silencer how long it takes the
police to come that's something that is
very premeditated in my opinion by the
way what a 180 from the way he appeared
back in the day to now just pretty
unbelievable but the discussion's not
going to end here because when we come
back police detail what they found at
Tim belief Nick's home that could tie in
with those very suspicious internet
searches stay with us
[Music]
foreign
key testimony in the trial of Tim
bleefnik he's the former Family Feud
contestant from Illinois accused of
shooting and killing his wife in the
last segment we uncovered internet
search history from the defendant's cell
phone he Googled questions such as how
to make a homemade pistol silencer and
can you identify if a shotgun shell was
shot out of a specific gun on Wednesday
a sergeant for the Quincy Police
Department went through items that were
found in belief Nick's home his
testimony may explain the motive behind
some of those searches
not only were there boxes of unfired
bullets
there were was were boxes of uh spent
shell casings this Winchester box that
we see here is that what you're talking
about where there were shell casings yes
when you found you go back there were
multiple shell casings found around
Becky police bodies on February 23 2023.
that's correct what caliber were those
in Shell cases nine millimeter in that
box
what
millimeter of shell casings that were
fired did you find nine millimeter in
common usage is referred to as as a gun
safe and
in your bedroom to possibly store guns
is that right yes did you in fact open
that gun safe yes
when you open that gun safe was there
anything in that gun safe in the
defendant's bedroom nothing at all you
said that there was a purchase a history
for the defendant as well with regard to
a nine millimeter yes what kind of
handgun was that uh there were two nine
millimeter handguns one being a Ruger
LC9 nine millimeter and one being a
Ruger SR9 nine millimeter
and in the course of XT in the search
warrant did you find one of those
handguns
the Ruger LC9 and that was seized and
taken to evidence it was and sent for
testing it was the other handgun that
you mentioned what was that I'm sorry a
Ruger SR9 nine millimeter was that found
anywhere in The Descendants residence no
so Mike looking ahead to next week
prosecutors they plan on calling for
Crime Lab professionals these are
witnesses from California multiple
detectives what do you think about that
testimony what should we be anticipating
well that testimony is always very
interesting because they bring forth
that testimony a lot of times there
aren't matches a lot of times what the
government will do is they'll show that
they've did a thorough investigation and
it'll explain why certain things don't
specifically match that's the kind of
testimony to really cut both ways in
front of a jury and it's very
interesting to see how they try to
connect it with other facts to make it
either more admissible or it's something
the defense wants to stay away from well
Terry let's focus in on what happened
this week for a second So based on the
items that were found in belief Nick's
home and the search history that we
talked a lot about you tell me how's the
prosecution doing how's their case
shaping up after week one of this trial
Jesse I watched some of this trial and I
definitely think the prosecution has a
leg up on this case first of all the
crime scene investigator who testified
said that there were all of these shell
casings at the crime scene and if they
can in fact match that all up to the
shell casings and the bullets and the
guns in the house and it seems like
they're on their way to do that of
course you can question it but it does
seem as though they'll be able to match
that all up that's very strong evidence
then they have the autopsy pictures and
the report and they tried to keep that
out the defense did not want that to
come in but it got in and I think some
of it is very gruesome and graphic and I
think the jury is going to be sueded by
that and then you know finally those
Google searches if you are searching how
to make a silencer and you are also
searching how to get gunpowder off your
hand and how long does it take the
police to respond that is definitely
consciousness of guilt assuming he
searched them the defense saying he
might not have put a little hard to
fight against that Mike Terry thank you
both so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on Long Prime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]
thank you